[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we had derived
this expression
uh or we had rewritten this expression
in terms
of this variable
w along with this bending rigidity what
we are going to do next is to substitute
this expression back
where we had left off earlier in our
derivation steps
right here right so what i'm going to do
is uh
just copy
this entire thing
which is the negative of the left hand
side
that we have been dealing with so this
thing
pop it in a new page
this is our
minus lhs bending
and this entire thing that i'm going to
replace
uh by minus d delta for w
all right let me do that immediately
minus d delta four
w
i'll just move this here
okay next uh what i'm going to do
is to put this minus sign from the left
hand side
back here so
this is minus
this becomes minus
this becomes a plus this becomes a plus
and this becomes a plus there we have
our left hand side considering only the
bending terms
next we are interested in finding out
the right hand side
and please uh note that this right hand
side
is the right hand side of our uh
our virtual work equation okay so back
when
we started uh our derivations
we had started from this side and we had
just started off with this left hand
side
now we are going to consider this right
inside here okay
so
we are going to consider this
ti delta ui
dna now uh what is the
so this is the this is the externally
applied load uh
what is this load okay so
let me go back to the
the first equation uh
the first page that we were considering
so this
diagram and here uh
i need to show the load the externally
applied load
in this particular fashion so
let there be some kind of a distributed
load
uh present
over this top surface that is at uh
z equal to minus h by 2
but please note that because of this
downward direction of z this is in the
positive
direction okay so
uh
let me get back to my page so this thing
can be written as
q delta w
d a so all that i have to do is really
to equate this thing with this thing and
please note that the right hand side
that i have written
that really is just considering the
bending term because
this kind of a load is what is going to
induce the bending
okay so you might as well write this as
the bending term all right now
if we equate these two things then
we are going to end up with
well i i wish to write these two things
together uh what i can do is
and just by the way uh
it is it is a little bit more explicit
uh and clearer if uh all these
terms involving the boundaries so
these integration terms
over the entire contour of our plate
that is expressed
[Music]
in terms of this cyclic integral so
that's what i'll do
and you will see that in the typeset
lecture notes
uh these are also presented in such
kinds of or denoted by such kinds of
cyclic intervals uh i don't have to put
the cyclic integral over this thing
okay so i'll make make it all consistent
all throughout
wherever i have those integrations
over the contour
i'll use the cyclic integrals
it doesn't make any difference to our
maths uh
but it's just more explicit this way
all right and we'll be also consistent
with the notation that we use in our
typeset notes
so uh if i if i if i just
copy this thing
and paste it here
um i am in a little bit of a trouble
here
because this entire thing won't fit here
okay i'll go to the next page
right i should do it so
uh but
basically i'm just doing this
all right now
of course i can i can bring this to this
left hand side
and do that
all right now
up here you please note that
a little bit of a little bit of
simplification
is still possible uh if
uh if we considered the stress
equilibrium equation so that's exactly
what you're going to do
consider the
stress equilibrium equation
along the x direction first
what is the stress equilibrium equation
in the x direction just simply
this del sigma x x del x plus
del sigma xy
del y plus del sigma
xz del z and please note
that uh we have already considered
we are already considering a situation
where
the boundary terms or the body force
terms
are being neglected so we don't have to
write that plus
rho bx
so what i'm going to do here is to
uh we'll multiply all these terms
by set
okay and then i'm going to integrate it
with uh respect to z okay so
integrate with respect to z
from minus h by 2 to h by 2.
so what i'm going to obtain uh
here is
let me just write that down
and you'll see in a moment uh the
motivation for
doing such a thing right now it may seem
a little bit
uh i mean none of the steps is wrong but
why are we even doing this may seem like
that but you'll
soon realize the motivation we i mean
the ultimate goal here is to come back
here
and to simplify some of these
expressions okay
next what we are going to do here is
to see
this z is oh well it is independent of x
so what we can do is we can put the z
inside here
similarly the z is certainly independent
of y so we can put this z inside here
uh and uh
so we'll do that and i'll show you a
certain simplification that is possible
but we can't do such a thing here for
this term
all right so uh
what we are going to do for this one is
to
carry out an integration by parts
okay so let me go to the next page
and continue with the steps
like so
for the second term
i have this
oh sorry
should be sigma xy
and then for the term involving the
integration with respect
or or the z sigma zx z
term
i'll have after the integration by parts
these boundary terms
and this integration term
right next to note
that
this del del x it can very well be taken
outside this
integration right so
if you are a little bit observant
mathematically
you can actually see that
there is a certain danger to writing
or doing such a thing that taking a
differentiation out of this integration
what i'm trying to say here is that you
need to respect
something called the leibniz rule but
for this particular case there is no
danger
because the upper limits and the lower
limits
they are constants okay so
if you are not familiar with the leibniz
rule i i seriously advise you
to please look it up okay now which
actually puts
that rule is regarding this taking the
differentiation that is present outside
an integration within the integration
so in this particular case it doesn't
really matter
but it will matter it would have
mattered had this these things
not been constants rather
some functions okay so uh for now
we just proceed similarly we take this
thing out
out of the integration
now this particular term this
uh this sigma xz of
on h by two and sigma x said on minus h
by two
they are actually zero okay so
you can can look from the diagram that
the only
uh loading that is
present uh that is along the z direction
there is no shear there
okay so these the sigma xz it represents
the shear stress
we don't have any shear stress on the
top surface and on the bottom surface
so this terms are zero uh these boundary
terms are 0
we are left with just this
next you note that this particular
combination we have already defined this
to be mine uh to be mx okay so this is
nothing but
mx this is nothing but
m y as we have been writing it up
earlier
and this particular term we have not
defined
up but we can do so up so let me write
this down
this is del mx del x
plus del
m y del y
sorry and this is this is actually sorry
my mistake this is mxy
because i have sigma xy here not sigma
yy
uh had this been sigma yy then this
would have been my
now this particular term that i am going
to define
as qx
i'll take this thing out to the right
hand side
so what we're doing here is to define
ux has
sigma xz
oh by the way i have made a mistake here
in the integration by parts because you
see
when i carry out the integration by
parts in the second term involving the
integration there is a ddz
of z okay there is a ddz
of z that should be done so
in the next step this thing is going to
disappear
okay
so this is just sigma xz dz
all right
so what is this uh what is this what
this is telling us
is that over a particular
edge of our plate so if our plate is
is going like that it is there okay
so this is this is the thickness of the
plate and
uh on this now on this edge
we have uh
taking a cut section through the plate
uh
over the thickness over that edge uh you
are going to
end up with stresses
which are which are like this so these
are our sigma
xz
you please note that when i am doing
such a thing i am
i am considering that
the x is coming out like this okay
so if we go back to our
first diagram here so what i'm doing
here is taking a cut section
which is perpendicular to the x-axis so
over that
over such a kind of a cut section over
the exposed edge
of such a cut section so
let me try to draw that here if i take a
cut section
in this fashion
all right and this is just for
demonstration purpose so this
this angle is 90 degree here if i take
such a cut section
then the exposed surface as a result of
that cut section
i'm considering that kind that that
thickness that edge
okay so i'll delete this thing to avoid
the clutter and get back to my
page
so i was working here all right
so here i have the sigma exit and it is
that sigma xz which is actually
contributing
to the ultimate shear force which is
represented by this
qx okay now
uh in exactly the same fashion
that we have obtained this equation uh
next if we consider
next consider the
stress equilibrium equation
in y direction so earlier as you can see
we have taken it along the x direction
now we are going to take it along the y
direction
so whatever what we're going to have is
del sigma xy del x
plus del sigma yy del y
plus del sigma y said
l said that is equal to 0 and if we
carry out
the exact same kind of steps that we
have just done for the
stress equilibrium equation along the x
direction that is multiplying throughout
by z
then integrating then what we are going
to obtain
is
del m xy del x
plus del m y del y
this m y i'll be getting from this term
and this m x y
i'll be getting from this term and from
here
uh what i'll obtain is a q
y where you please note that
we are defining uy
to be minus h by 2
to h by 2 sigma y z
e z
and you can uh interpret this shear
force
uh by taking similarly ah
a cut section which is perpendicular to
the y axis
in just the same way that we have done
here yeah so
uh so uh so if we get back to our steps
what does this what does this really
tell us okay
uh if we just take a look there
um here
you see i do have a term
involving the del mx del x i do have a
term involving the del
mx y del x
sorry del mx y del y and the good thing
here
is that i have missed a delta w but you
please note
that barring that that error
cut it that immediately
up this nx and we also have an nx here
we have nx here we have nx here so it is
very much possible
to take this term common with this term
similarly it is possible to take
this term which has a n y here common
with this term
this delta del m y del y
with this n y okay so
let me copy this entire thing again
okay uh first of all i will
i will take this term
common with this term
so whatever was present in the in the in
the first line
that will remain as it is i'll just copy
paste from
there
but here what i will have
is this
delta mx del mx del x
plus del m x
y del y
n x delta w
ds cyclic integral
over the entire contour and next
i'll take this term common with
this term so that i obtain
del m x y del x from here
plus del m y
del y multiplied by
n y which is present over here as well
as here
and then the delta w yes
and then i'll have this system
integration over the entire area d
delta 4 w minus q
delta w d a
so i can replace this thing but by what
i had obtained
in the previous page uh this was q x
and this was u y you can just check
uh this entire thing is qx and this
entire thing
is q y so
back here uh i'll be able to make that
substitution
so i'll copy this entire thing here go
to the next page and write down that
equation
so
this entire thing becomes
ux
i shift this here
and then
this is ui and i ship this here
i'll just shift this thing here
all right so this entire thing is equal
to zero
right
[Music]
now this is as far as we can go here
uh without uh i mean
in terms of the simplifications that are
possible
now the next step and this is
this is where it gets uh
quite involved as far as the is
concerned
we are going to convert these equations
written with respect to the x y
coordinate system
uh in or with respect to
a coordinate system now which will be
like a body
fitted coordinate system so what we are
saying
is that if i just uh i just go back
to this diagram and maybe copy paste
copy this thing out
we have been referring to this x y
coordinate system
but what i want to do now is to
is to go to an
equivalent picture so
if i look at look at it from the top
down
i am going to look at it and i'm going
to find the shape
to be of this fashion something close to
this
uh not the perfect of transpositions
but uh bear with me here so uh
our x
is like this our y is like this
and z is going into the
into the plane of the screen are
represented by this cross
now what i really want to do here
is uh is to consider
a coordinate system which will be body
fitted like this
okay so our i'll consider
a coordinate system which is now which
is
s like this and n like this so s
is along the contour and n is everywhere
perpendicular to the contour and it
makes
sense to treat it in this fashion
because you note
that in the process of these previous
steps we have
basically integrated uh
in all these terms we have integrated
through the thickness with respect to z
from minus h by 2 to h by 2. so you see
none of these terms explicitly contain
any integration with respect to z that
has already been taken care of or some
somehow been absorbed
within the terms so all that is left is
a consideration over the over this
domain
so it is as if we are only concentrating
on the
the flat mid surface on the mid surface
of this plate
so and
and you see overall this term here is
over the entire domain
but all of these terms okay uh
these terms are over than that boundary
so
so that is kind of the motivation here
is that
we wish to go to a coordinate system
which would be
uh distributed over this or which would
be tracking this entire contour here
okay one good thing here is that even if
we convert our entire equations to the
to another coordinate system like this
sn
it would not make any difference to this
term here because you see this has been
written in this
uh tensor notation this delta 4
or this operator notation and that
particular form
uh that won't be affected by a different
choice of the coordinate system
okay so so that's good news
and uh and our hope is that if
we go from the x y coordinate system to
the s sn coordinate system
then perhaps these terms will also
be somewhat simplified but but the price
that will have to pay for
eventually arriving at such a simplified
form
will be uh will be some uh due
labor uh in the process of doing it
so on that note i will end this video
and in the next one we'll continue with
that
uh with that transformation from the x y
coordinate system to the
s encoded system thank you very much